good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and happy hump day i
almost did my friday jingles make sure
to subscribe for exciting days
i just got too excited about the home
thing you know i know i mean i'm really
excited that it's hump day i have a
tribute to boo to do
oh my god i didn't even notice you were
wearing that on my sweater today
unfortunately my mic covers my
left breast you want to switch seats for
the shower i think that we should out of
respect
no the people get so i cannot function
on that side so twisted they're right
it's the most moronic thing like i can't
sit on that side okay plus i like my
situation here and i got my tings that's
the side where i used to have my mole so
like i have a lot of trauma from it you
have this you have right side trauma i
have mold trauma i'm an old woman
um i hope everyone had a great day you
know what i think we should start
calling hump day bump day because you're
bumping these days i um that works yeah
happy bump day happy bump day to me yeah
no i got a big big belly how's the belly
feeling the belly's feeling good you
know just moving and grooving any
complaints no oh i mean back and feet
back and feet did zach rub them he does
and have you used the home medics foot
massager yes i have so in the like when
i wake up in the morning is when i feel
my best for the day i have the most
energy you feel like p diddy
wake up in the i literally thought
that's what you're going to say i don't
know i like because i've just like been
off my feet for 10 hours right so i'm
feeling rested i'm feeling good i have
my coffee and then just throughout the
day i deteriorate it's what happens but
how great is your life like thank god
that you work in the mornings right
right but by the end of the day like i
can't stand up i can bend over like back
breaking
food breaking but you know what it's
actually making me obviously i'm not to
make everything about me
actually that's exactly what i'm doing
but like you know i have a lot of
anxiety about pregnancy i just don't
think i would handle it well knowing
that our current
lifestyle is literally structured for
pregnancy like you're very blessed yeah
and you would think that probably
morning sickness would be like right you
know collide with morning show
but
i
i thought i found it to be fine okay and
i really did find that even when i was
at my nauseous phase it came in the
afternoon for me and a lot of people
have said that too like it's really not
the mornings well i've heard that like
that's like a classic thing but i do
like wake up step out into my living
room and do a nice big gag every day
still like
you guys just like wait for it to waft
over me i'm like
one of these days we have to catch it on
a patreon vlog i have been in jackie's
presence for one of her
gags and when i think gag i think like
actually if you like a gag trigger like
don't listen to this jackie's like a
full-blown yelp it's like
it's it's alarming like if you're not
expecting it it will scare you yeah yeah
no it comes like sometimes i'll open the
fridge gag but like every day i'm gonna
make my coffee give it a second
get the gag out move on oof yeah and
then sometimes like that gag is a
nefarious gag it's in the fairy skag
right right now and i gotta hit the
toilet no it's hard to know which is
gonna be a nefarious gag and which is
gonna be the benevolent gag right so i
mean i haven't had a nefarious one in a
while because now i'm like at the next
stage of you'd be with like back how
many months are you
six and change people keep asking me i'm
like 11. i literally don't know
i don't know i'm like two i really don't
know six and change six and change okay
cool yeah
um well i had an eventful evening first
of all i just have to say this is not an
ad even though they are a sponsor i
recently got fresh um
bowling brand sheets
and i put them on last wednesday and i
have not slept like this like in a
lifetime you actually called me to rave
about them it it's not even an ad i
swear no it's not but it sounds like one
i have just been sleeping like
a dead woman like you could not you
could set off a nuclear bomb and i would
sleep through it like it's just been
amazing that's amazing i'm just sleeping
so well and that never happened so i
feel like i have to acknowledge the
space that i'm in yeah i think it's also
the daylight savings yes influence
totally just a lot of factors plus you
know we have a chill in the air you're
not as overheated 100
and i just think it's a culmination of
things that is leading to better sleep
for all of us including bowling brand
sheets yeah no you're 100 right and i'm
just very grateful to be like in this
moment in this space yeah um but i also
had an eventful evening because you know
i never leave my house but i went to an
event last night
that was so premium like and so filled
with stars which never happens because
you know as
major influences in this community we
get invited to so many events and
honestly for the most part like i
stopped going to events a few years ago
like because they're all terrible like
yeah they're just not fun and they're
like boring and the food stinks i went
to such a pr so awkward we talked about
this on a patreon episode our last uh
episode that's a podcast we talk about
the awkwardness of being an influencer
and attending these events and yeah i
was literally peeing with laughter it
was so funny and it's so true and so i
haven't been to one forever just because
like i i don't have the stomach for it
um
joke about my stomach um but i went to
one last night that was so premium first
of all like every influencer in town was
in there and i finally got to meet
sophia la court
who is an up-and-coming star who's so
gorgeous in real life and was such a
lovely person like i just couldn't
believe i was talking to someone that
was so beautiful and so nice no she's
everything of the sort and i'm so glad
that you got to meet her i'm obsessed
with her when we spotted each other from
across the room it was like seeing like
someone i've known for 15 years we were
like screaming that's so sweet and
obviously my boyfriend tyler c was there
which was just really good it was kind
of awkward because ben was my plus one
so it was like kind of
uncomfortable to be like they like have
their own thing going on too obsessed
and then then when you add theo to the
mix it's like this orgy so i did want to
like let everyone know that tyler did
ask about theo he did ask about the
podcast he misses the toasters he asked
about them
because he was uh telling me i guess
wherever he goes whether toasters are
always like we loved you on the toast
which is so nice because it makes us
look like so legit to tyler no when that
happens to celebrities never forget
yosemite um yes no was it yosemite or
yellow it's yosemite because i remember
i said yosemite and everyone dragged me
okay yeah that's dragged me through the
national park there are toasters in high
places yosemite is seared into my brain
for those who don't know yosemite is a
national park where luke combs had a day
off on his tour and wanted to go in and
the security guard would not let him in
they were closed his tour bus was too
big it was like a whole thing they're
like he's like i'm luke combs and they
were like we don't care and this like
national park
ranger came on the ranger girly ranger
girly came on i think her name was laura
she came on the bus to explain like why
you know the bus was too big and it was
the hours were right and she was a
toaster and she was like wait
niko i saw you on the toes like on cmas
and she was like yeah he's like oh you
guys can come right in
so that's what i'm saying toasters in
high places also you may not know this
because the event was for amazon last
night did you know um like 90 of the
people who work for amazon are toasters
no i met so many amazing toasters
colleen reese sam like i meant all these
toasters who are just like making amazon
happen that's why it's a trillion dollar
company and that's what people don't
talk about wow what side of amazon are
they on all aspects so they're the pr
company the event company that put on
the amazon event autumn communications
riddled with toasters then the actual
amazon amazon fashion amazon school like
every single sector is infested with
toasters and that's why you see this
unparalleled historic growth from amazon
wow there's an infestation infestation
you absolutely love to see it that's why
it's such a good time i was just like
around like-minded individuals and
celebrities kathy hilton and kyle
richards were like the they were like
hosting the event um did see kyle her
nose looked amazing and i was like your
nose looks amazing she was like i'm so
glad i broke it
and it was just like kind of a fabulous
holiday party and i it reinvigorated my
love for what i do you know wow that's
so beautiful yeah no and like i like
hate going to things and it was in
brooklyn you know like i had to get up
and go yeah but amazon is classy like
they send a car like they are just
elegant i'm so glad you had such a great
evening
i really did and then i got home at like
10 30 and passed out in my amazing bed
like it was kind of like a perfect night
wow that's
really nice for you i actually had a
great night too and everyone was asking
about you ever really sophia court
especially she was like tyler c
um no that's okay he hasn't it's been a
while have you
he replaced you so have you ever met him
yes because he came on the show as a
guest once oh right right right right
right like we went to his apartment
party yeah
we're old friends i was there yeah no i
just forgot because my most like obvious
memory with tyler is him sitting right
there making love to my son understood
did he say anything about the marathon
yes oh my god so he was there with his
home friend chad who was such a nice guy
and he was like so cute and i was like i
was actually like thinking like maybe
him and sofia court like cause because
sophia court was hanging with me what
about sophia according tyler c
oh yeah that too but like tyler was busy
so like we were all talking to chad okay
and so but they both ran the marathon
together i was like did you guys cry and
they were like no i'm like why what's
the point
literally and i said you guys have to
like pee or anything that was my
question and they were like you actually
they have like bathroom stations like
porta potties um along the way but they
didn't pee because they tried not to
like drink a lot of water and stuff i
wonder what the porta-potties like what
level of um i can't even imagine
is it like you know coachella vip no i
think it's like port-a-potty
porta john you know got it but then this
guy chad told me the craziest thing that
i haven't been able to stop thinking
about i'm like well what are your
ailments like are your legs hurting like
how are you here right now and he was
like showing me this picture and he was
like honestly like my body's fine he
shows me this picture where his
tank top is like red but it's like a
white tank top i'm like what is that
he's like my nipples were bleeding
because like you're you're chafing
running up against your shirt yeah and
that was just like an unforeseen damage
that he had had
and he said like literally they're
scabbing
i don't know if i should be like blowing
up his spot right now like using his
name but he was such a nice guy and he
was just like sharing he's like and then
tyler he said flicked his nipple and
he's never been in so much pain in his
life oh my god he needs like a sports
bra i wonder if that happens to the
women or no we're protected we're
protected but i think like chafing
between the legs like no matter how
great shape you're in like you're
running passing your thighs back so many
times like you're gonna change even the
most in-shaped person also underarms oh
yeah so that's why people wear like
biker shorts under armour like
undergarments you have to like really
prepare and so if it was their first
marathon they didn't know
wow
wow
wow yeah no i know every time i think
about it like i'd like grasp on it like
it really pains me it's like one of
those eek moments marathon fun fact yeah
no i was learning a lot
interesting and tyler said he was like
making amazing time until like the 21st
mile and he was like i was dead like my
hamstring was broken like and he said he
like trained but you know he's like
he's a good [ __ ] like yeah yeah so he
yeah he made it to the 21st mile until
he was like a dead man
wow but his time was like four hours and
20 minutes or maybe five hours and 20
minutes pretty good really good really
good pretty good like pretty good yeah
as i say for my couch yeah so it was
just an interesting evening full of
interesting people i'm so glad to hear
it thank you
so i guess we can get right into
everything i know you didn't watch
vanderpump rules but listen what is one
thing we've learned about me like i
never backed down from a challenge i
watched it this morning okay but you
told me last night you were like i'm not
gonna watch yeah so you don't need to
watch but then you said i am gonna watch
right oh so then you were you were
watching if you had confirmed with me
last night that we would be off the hook
i would have you know i just i had the
bandwidth so did i this morning okay
cool so we'll recap that even though it
was a big
steamy pile of dump waste of time yeah
and
yeah i'm still reading good morning
monster it is so good oh yeah it's so
good i'm on story person number three
and like each person
comes from
more interesting set of circumstances
than the last it's while i'm learning so
much about human behavior
and
i'm really enjoying i'm really enjoying
maybe it'll like influence and actually
it actually already is influencing like
how i think about things because
everybody is just like a culmination of
all the different things in their life
and like so someone might have like
weird quirky things about them and it's
not just like them being or you know
it's like maybe when they were five
years old like they didn't have the
opportunity to ha to make that sort of
is that what you're thinking like about
tom sandoval oh
no i wasn't thinking about him in
particular but he is like quirky no it
does make me think twice about like
making fun even like a friend for your
week something that you never know you
just never know so true so i'm like like
dana for her rehearsal dinner like i'm
roasting her and i'm like
so
good like i am so devastato i'm not
gonna be there because it's gonna kill
like okay it sounds like it was written
by like literally like
jeff ross like roast master like it's so
good
and you're also just like very well
spoken and articulate like you use big
words it's just it's really good like
honestly if dana will let you like you
should record it for the patreon okay i
think she would be totally fine with
that and also you guys don't know this
about me but like i am
i hate public speaking like especially
when it's like a room full of people
that i know you know like when we have
what's worse when we've done like live
shows and stuff i'm able to like
just be with you yeah but when i have to
like put my own words and feelings pen
to paper oh yeah share them like it
gives me so much anxiety but also the
aspect of it being people you know like
i would literally rather perform in
front of 10 000 strangers than 20 of my
closest friends and family like it's
[ __ ] painfully off yeah and speaking
about like your
most feelings yeah
but anyway so that's been um a nice
journey and actually i'm really i'm
liking this nonfiction
turn that i've taken because i was
getting
i was getting into a weird place with
reading where i just like had nowhere to
turn real
real nonfiction yes okay yes exactly
cool cool
so without further ado yeah there was
something on my mind but it slept it'll
come back i'm sure it will it always
does
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
do you hear that
um
[Music]
yeah that is i was right i did hear
something it is bruce you guys the
unofficial official
let me start that over today's episode
is brought to you by bruce the official
toothbrush of the morning oh my god i
almost said breath the morning toast
because i was thinking like brush sorry
um okay if you're looking for an
electric toothbrush stop looking we have
the best and most affordable one because
electric toothbrushes are fabulous but a
lot of them most of them can cost over
two hundred dollars which honestly is
just asinine and stupid so bruce is here
to give you the best looking the best
working and the best priced electric
toothbrush on the market it comes with
six unique modes so you can customize
the entire brushing experience the
battery life lasts four weeks it comes
with a magnetic charging stand a compact
travel case which is so fabulous both of
these items and because the battery life
lasts four weeks you literally don't
have to bring the charger with you if
you're going on like a vacation for a
week or two weeks
they also offer a subscription program
so you never forget to change your brush
head again bruce will ship you new
replacement heads every six months so
you're never stuck using a worn down
brush head their electric toothbrush has
a modern aesthetically pleasing design
it comes in trend driven seasonal colors
and it looks great on your bathroom
counter get 15 off your brush toothbrush
kit and the refill plan when you use
promo code toast at bruce.com toast
that's 15 off using promo code toast at
b-r-u-u-s-h-dot-com
toast
wonderful get your brutace
first story
people's 2021 sexiest man alive is here
and it is
paul rudd cute
paul rodd is having a hard time
accepting his new title of people's
sexiest man alive the actor has heard it
all kind self-defecating affable
hard-working all labels he's embraced to
some degree but sexy that's a little
outside his wheelhouse he said i do have
an awareness enough to know that when
people hear that i'd be picked for this
they would say what he he says to people
magazine this is not false humility
there are so many people that should get
this before me
okay paul rudd let's discuss
because there is a community of people
obsessed would take a bullet who would
take a bullet whose life has been made
by this distinction yeah who feels seen
who feel heard and i just want to
address you quickly i'm happy for you me
too know that i am know that i am even
if i
don't understand now here's the thing
when when i saw this my reaction was
literally cute like yeah paul ryan is a
hundred percent very handsome he gets
better with age would i say he's the
sexiest man alive no what do you think
he's the cutest man alive yeah like he's
super cute he doesn't
give off that like raw sex appeal but i
feel like this is a really good safe
choice like i'm not mad about it like
it's not offensive i'm not controversial
nobody has beef with paul rudd even if
you're not on stan
stannis baratheon warship like you are
just like oh he's a cute guy like i love
clueless like he's always in some good
[ __ ] and he seems like an all-around
stand-up guy like let's value that as
sexy cool i completely agree because
really and i feel like i was just saying
this to someone like sexiness and just
like good looks really nothing that
should be like so you know like mother
teresa
have so it's confusing your guys are so
so similar but like
at the end of the day once you know
someone it has like nothing to do with
how they look like one how you talk your
confidence your personality your
ambiance like that really can make
someone like pete davidson who i think
looks wise it's like a five out of ten
everything else 10 out of 10. like it's
not about your looks anymore no it's so
true like you're
especially for me like
the first time i meet you i guess i'm
registering your looks but after that
like the way that i see you is based on
who you are and i feel like a really
good example of that is the bachelor
because like 25 those all those guys are
dropped handsome technically classically
whatever but then like we spend two
minutes hearing from them and it's like
get this man on my face a hundred
percent you know when it's like you like
but it also can be the opposite like you
could be so handsome and like literally
what comes out of your mouth is like
dull boring stupid bye like it can make
you uglier too no that's what i'm saying
that's why we shall be working on our
personality it just like nullifies your
handsomeness and it's like i i can't be
bothered but then you could have someone
who's you know every no one's really
like that ugly no thing is we're really
uh we're literally being like what's not
mother teresa like the nursery right
mother goose
i don't think i keep saying mother
teresa but that's not it no what are you
trying to say
i was like gonna say something like
cliche and like nursery rhymey so like
what is that
it's not mother teresa it's cause that's
like a
she's like a religious figure yeah
because she's a saint so she's just it
it works no but it's a plain king of
another mother someone's gonna know what
i'm talking about like in nursery rhymes
and [ __ ] mother goose is a from nursery
rhymes yeah but i don't think it's
mother goes okay okay we're being very
after school special but yeah yeah but
you know what that's like what you learn
when you're
a kid and you roll your eyes at it but
like as an adult it's so true like you
just spend your life with someone okay
you're like
conventionally hot but you're like
boring and mean and stupid like who
cares you're the ugliest person on the
inside yeah do you feel like not
everyone has reached this like level of
enlightenment and like those are the
people who just like make terrible
choices and partners 100 but
it's just a level of i guess it's like a
maturity thing but i don't know it's
just a
a you spend a lot of time with this
person like right you want to enjoy
yourself now the thing with paul rudd is
like i don't know if i've ever told this
story but like i have like a paul rudd
anecdote do you know what i'm about to
say no this might be is this a fresh
claudius i don't think so i remember
saying it before but okay what was the
place called where we used to do
gymnastics growing up as kids
gymnastics i had like a name like not
gymnastics but like
five-star five-star gymnastics remember
so we had just seen the movie clueless
we were like obsessed and i forget how
old i was but we were in our gymnastics
class and the guy who like ran my
like group looked so much i didn't know
it was paul ryan i'm like you look like
josh from clueless like that's all what
i thought and they got i know i sound
crazy like i
no i sound crazy
i thought it's so hard and like one day
i said it to him like you look so much
like the guy from clueless josh and he
gave me like this like smirk and he was
like i like you know i was on to him
and then like he stopped working at the
gymnastics place like obviously because
he came famous and i'm telling you i'm
telling you paul rudd taught me
gymnastics like
i know it sounds moronic but if i ever
meet paul rudd i have to ask him if he
ever taught gymnastics in long island
like it has been something it is
something that has like eaten me alive
and like kept me up at night
i know i sound crazy like i know
paul read tommy gymnastics
you've definitely never told that story
i've like i know have you committed
i'm telling you if anyone knows paul
rudd like please this has been something
that is plaguing me my entire life like
because i know that this happened you
know but i also have like a lot of
childhood trauma so like maybe i did
make it up but i'm telling you like it
totally happened
i know it
okay you know what this is your stanley
chu channel plane moment i'm gonna like
no don't gasp at me like that because we
were all there we were all adults we saw
that it wasn't stanley teaching like
you're just being funny by joking that
it was stanley tucci it was stanley
sushi and on the off chance that it
wasn't it was the guy from kingsman
very possible but it was not stanley
tucci we were all there you guys like
don't know what i'm talking about so it
makes it seem like this is an even more
far-off idea
i'm telling you
paul rudd taught me gymnastics i know it
so if anyone city is even remotely close
to paul rod like related to him like
works for like something please just
like ask him if he ever taught
gymnastics in long island like it will
save me like so much therapy like please
okay and that's your truth
oh [ __ ] off it's the truth no no it's
not even close to the truth but it could
be your truth
unless this guy who was teaching me
gymnastics i should call the gymnastics
place
take a look at their records
if they're still open
you guys we've lost her i feel like now
that i've kind of like said my truth
people will start coming out of the
woodwork like oh my god paul red taught
me also
okay
well you know what does anyone know what
i'm talking about like i do you know
crazy space to explore this yeah please
and then like if i'm wrong i'm wrong but
yeah yeah yeah when you're wrong
but i just like needed to get that off
my chest it's been like plaguing me for
the longest time okay and now he's the
sexiest man alive yeah and i did that it
was me at gymnastics who gave him the
confidence definitely he does look
really good on the cover
so
i think this is this is great i've
actually been like ever since we did
that quiz i was like when are they going
to give us the sma oh yeah and oh i
forgot that we did that like poll yeah
and
i'm glad that now we know you know
because how would we go on if we didn't
know who the sexiest man alive was you
know what's so funny about the sexiest
man alive thing it's like they get they
always nominate or give it to an
a-lister
who would literally never be associated
with people magazine ever like do you
think paul rudd would ever sit down for
an interview with people magazine like
george clooney
sort of
because when you think of actually like
sexiest man alive like harry styles you
know right it's always an older man it's
always someone who's like you know has a
new show coming out could use a little
press does he have a new something
coming out yes the shrink next door on
apple plus got it with will ferrell yeah
it is weird that they always do like
a much older it's always like blake
shelton george clooney brad pitt like
older
men when like actually you're right like
the hottest man alive right now by like
society's terms is harry styles davidson
right but there he's not joining people
magazine no to talk about his sexiness
that's true you know so it's like
sexiest man alive that we have access to
did they release the other like sexiest
hair alive no i wasn't seeing sexiest
hair but some stuff had been like
trickling in recently but i'm sure
hopefully tomorrow we'll have the full
list and we can we can see if this hair
really is sexy yeah we'll be the judge
of that whenever we say sexy so many
times i feel like anna farrison house
bunny so sexy oh i thought you were
gonna say whatever you know when you say
a word a lot of times it starts to sound
weird yes no that's not what i meant i
cannot say the word garage more than
like three times without having to go to
the hospital
okay well you have two more stories
don't do it
garage
you guys she's done
someone get paul rudd to resuscitate her
make her do a cartwheel
okay i'm better thanks paul okay are you
ready for our next story
sure switching gears a bit uh new
information has come out that travis
scott attended david buster's party
after astroworld
travis scott attended an after party at
dave and buster's following the
astroworld festival tragedy but he was
unaware at the time that several con
several concert goers had been trampled
to death a report said the rapper quote
didn't know the severity of the
situation when he arrived to the party a
source told tmz but once he was informed
he immediately left the after party was
thrown by drake who made a surprise
appearance at friday's opening day of
the festival in houston drake also did
not initially know the extent of the
tragedy when he went to the arcade for
the party according to tmz i mean this
is just
no bueno like
everything that has come out like since
it's just so bad for travis like this is
horrible yeah like we knew
yeah it was like trending on twitter
like how did we know and you didn't i
don't know but i think
this
i i really don't think that he knew when
he i don't think he went to dave
investors like knowing that his concert
was a mass casualty event
but it's like how how do you know how
where are your people right like i
[ __ ] knew right but like i could
imagine maybe his phone is he's not on
for sure no i'm not thinking he's
trolling twitter like what are people
saying about my concerts but he has a
million people around him people
handlers managers who are like
constantly taking the temperature right
of what they just put on like this huge
festival right
no i'm i have a hard time believing this
and this is just like such a bad look
for travis it's such a bad look but i i
mean it's so bad that i i believe that
he did not know
i just think like i honestly i don't
know how traffic is also like you said
he cut the show it was supposed to be
175 minutes he made it shorter so like
what was clean
right what was his reasoning for making
it shorter now it's a flaw in his story
because he said on his instagram like we
cut the show short even though people
were like you could have should have cut
it way shorter you did like 20 minutes
less so if you did cut it short you knew
something was wrong but you still went
to an after party
but to what extent did he know that
something was wrong maybe he thought
that just the crowd was getting out of
control
like maybe but it just this is so bad
like i've been thinking about it a lot
like i don't know how career-wise travis
scott bounces back from this
this is like a career-ending
moment you think so i mean i don't know
how he's gonna he's being dropped from
festivals left right and center i
thought he was replaced by um
post malone thank you um
no one wants to be associated with that
right now and of course like that always
dies down the news cycle picks up
something else but i just think people
are so disturbed by this story like on
an emotional i don't know how you can
see the picture of the 10 year old boy
in a coma the 14 year old boy who died
and the unidentifiable man who they had
to release a picture of him from the
morgue like i don't know he did identify
him by the way yeah but what's crazy he
traveled from washington for the um
for the concert and his family like
didn't hear from him that night so they
thought something was wrong and they
called
the houston pd like is there anyone
who's not identified who has passed away
and they said no so they assumed he was
okay
and then they had to find out on social
media oh my god see like that's the
thing this is such like a like we're all
human like to hear all of us it's so
horrible and it's like so it's like
impacting everyone i can't stop thinking
about it and it's all over our news
feeds like i really don't know how we
move on from this like it's so
devastating and
the more we learn and the more videos we
see like we see a lot of the
responsibility is on travis and so i
don't know how he has a career after
this like for real and also people are
now surfacing like old posts yeah his
where
um there are photos of people who got
like injured at his concerts and it was
before you know this astro world was
sort of like a badge of honor to
come out with a bruise or a broken leg
or in a wheelchair right and so it it
it all encourages this behavior right
and now knowing what we know seeing it
all it looks terrible right it's been
going on since 2015. also some internal
documents came out about their like
safety protocols where they
said that they if you know like what to
do in an emergency at this festival and
they uh had plans to refer to possible
dead fans as smurfs yeah
which is so disturbing so disturbing it
reminds me of um succession
no real person involved yeah like a
terrible way of
describing
it that's the thing it's like all these
things that keep coming out are just
getting worse and worse and when you
look at it like you take a step back you
realize that this was
completely
unavoidable based on how they put this
thing together like it was always like
it had to like there was no way there
wasn't one thing someone could have done
like this was just a
a really poorly
constructed festival
with
a performer who encourages this type of
like violent behavior yeah so
it's just so terrible it's like the
worst thing i can't get over it like
it's so sad it's so sad and even more
details like some of the injured victims
are either
brain dead yeah i saw that um completely
brain dead or like in like fighting for
their lives so it's not just injured
like it's a broken leg
people are still like fighting for their
lives yeah
it's it's horrible so people are really
angry and i do feel like they're
completely justified in directing that
anger towards
travis but also
live nation is immensely responsible
because like so when you're a performer
like you put on an event obviously
you're not you don't have the capability
of what a live nation does so you
partner with a live nation and you think
that a lot of these things like security
like you know just regular like boring
administrative stuff should be taken
care of by live nation and they are
extremely responsible for that yeah well
the lawsuits there was a 26 million
insurance policy the lawsuits that are
coming in
people are saying like could go up into
the hundreds of millions of dollars
right so from travis and then going
forward it's like what venue would have
travis perform right
and also so when you're a performer
um
you have all different types of
insurance like i have insurance like if
somebody trips and falls in a venue i
don't want to be liable for their you
know broken tooth or something so
every performer has insurance i'm sure
travis does too
so
it's possible that his insurance will
cover all of these lawsuits but also he
will never be able to be insured again
so i don't know how you can't perform
without insurance like yeah so
i don't know i can't imagine there's
ever a insurance company who wants to
insure him because it's such a liability
so
again i don't know how he performs ever
again live yeah wow
and live nation is also royally [ __ ]
yeah
yeah
crazy crazy
are you ready for our next story switch
things up a little bit
please prince george ate a live and like
a hero reveals adventure bear grylls
what prince george was hanging out with
bear grylls because he bear grylls is
like a crocodile dundee person man
versus wild yeah right okay uh and he's
like the guy
in the in the uk especially and prince
george is a big fan and they're so cute
bear grylls appeared on good morning
britain on tuesday and he looked back at
his august 29 encounter with the little
prince who the british adventurer says
was a little hero for eating a live ant
the moment happened at the king's cup
regatta on the isle of wight when
george's grandmother carol middleton
invited girls over to meet the prince a
huge fan girls explained that he didn't
really mean to encourage george to eat
an ant that day but the moment presented
itself and he couldn't resist
he said and so we were chatting and he
was down here and just as we were
chatting a stream of ants went across
his feet and him and me looked at them
and he looked at me with those amazed
wide eyes and i said come on we've got
to eat one what
i didn't encourage the prince to eat up
and come on let's eat them
and he said oh really and we ate he said
it was a privilege to give the future
king his first hand and his eyes lit up
as they do with anyone when they're out
in the wild and they face a few fears
and they overcome them so good for him
what a little hero kids are so stinking
cute so stinking cute what does bear
gorillas look like grillous grills on
the right and that's why you watch what
happens live i guess
[Laughter]
that is so cute
imagine just like being the prince and
like you're just everywhere you go you
get to meet your heroes like i know you
know kids are so obsessed with like
disney prince like all these people that
they see in television and movies and
just to be the prince and like oh
daddy i'd like to see bagrillas like you
just get to see anyone you want like
that's such a life you also like become
a monster but it's so sweet and you
become so you know nothing amazing
and nothing can like
stun you impressively impress and he's
so little but like i mean i'm glad that
he had his anti-experience
he's an anti-file no and you know what
it really makes me think of the prince
on hbo max like that is literally what
he's going to turn into when you've
literally just been given everything in
your whole life yeah but this story you
know we don't get to know much about
prince george's personality um but this
story like
just gives me
a little insight a little bit and i'm
liking what i'm seeing yeah no he's
gonna make a great king it's a very
brave thing to do it is
i just can't believe like currently
right now there's like so many kings
alive like future kings right
charles hopefully not but yeah charles
william george like there's three
future kings alive right now isn't that
crazy yeah the britons i mean not the
britons the british just like live
forever
well you know
medicine is a wonderful thing yeah
is she the oldest living monarch like
and she has to be right yeah
and she's the longest reigning queen
literally literal queen our next story
is also about the literal queen you're
gonna die and the story brought to you
by zip recruiter did you know that there
are over 10 million job openings but
only 7.6 million unemployed job seekers
and this issue is being worsened due to
mismatch of employers and qualified
candidates so employers are having to go
above and beyond to entice people to
want to work for them enter zip
recruiter a powerful technology to find
and match the right candidates up with
your job then it proactively presents
these candidates to you you can easily
review these recommended candidates and
invite your top choices to apply for
your job which encourages them to apply
faster
ziprecruiter is the number one rated
hiring site in the us based on g2
ratings and it's no wonder their
technology is so effective that four out
of five employers who post unzip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the first day and now you can try zip
recruiter for free at the exclusive
address
ziprecruiter.com
toast that's ziprecruiter.com
t-o-a-s-t to try zip recruiter for free
zip recruiter the smartest way to hire
okay next story the queen will weigh
kate middleton and prince william after
christmas lunch as part of a bizarre
tradition
oh i could never be royal
in our family we all like to boast about
how much food we can tuck away on
christmas day but when you're a royal it
turns out you have to put your money
where your mouth is yes as if as if
christmas at the queen's norfolk estate
sandringham didn't sound daunting enough
there's also a very odd tradition that
every member of the royal family has to
follow in 2018 royal experts said that
the queen asks each of her guests
including kate and prince william to
weigh themselves when they arrive using
a set of antique scales but this is all
to make sure guests are having a great
time and they're being weighed to make
sure they're being well fed the
tradition dates back to king edward the
seventh reign in the early 1900s and
applies to all members of the royal
family that's atrocious
like literally [ __ ] atrocious never
invite me to sandringham before this
episode if you would have told me like
where's your dream to spend christmas
i'm like with the royals and centering
him now you have never played never you
have to get wait do they do it in front
of the group like i don't know like i
can't imagine you know if they're
weighing you out in the public like i
can't imagine that they're then
sensitive about them right right no like
they're doing it all in front of
everyone but you know they're all just
like so tiny it doesn't even matter yeah
but oh my god i can't the trauma the
trauma poor kate
that's just a lot you know she's already
like and like
you know when you're a woman in those a
young woman in those types of scenarios
like you're being picked apart in the
media constantly like i'm sure you have
such a negative body image oh great
finally i get to spend christmas with my
family and what do they do they weigh me
yeah disgusting isn't that wild that's
so bizarre i'm telling you british
people have like weird [ __ ] you know
yeah this is such a british thing i mean
and then you they weigh you like i guess
at the end of the meal to see how much
like food
ate and that you are well fed like who
literally ate the most it's just
embarrassing it's atrocious even though
this is
the stupidest thing i'm ever gonna say
but
when you get weighed in
london like uk
you don't get weighed in pounds right no
stones yeah okay so like i probably
weigh like what like 11 stones like
that's so little you know yeah but it's
like less embarrassing when the number
isn't that high no to them though like
stones are pounds so like they're it's
just relative no i know but like there's
just something about saying like
150 or 11. i don't know what the right
conversion is but like there's something
more
acceptable like to me about that you
know okay
okay so maybe i should move to london i
think i'd be skinny weightless yeah
literally okay ready for our fifth and
final story
not yet hold on
places people
it's the final story
to do
[Music]
in public
[Applause]
that was like a nice slight final story
not everyone has to be 100 i like when
we switch it up we give it different
energy on different days you know
our fifth and final story is a really
sweet story so i don't know if you've
seen the trailer for the new movie
coming out called king richard with will
smith
serena and venuses yes yes serena and
venus it's the story of them and their
dad who's their coach and like their
childhood and tennis and everything will
smith says venus and serena williams
cried all the way through king richard
they loved it that's really sweet and
they were involved
in i was watching the today show and
they said like this is venus and serena
approved okay that's great which is so
important to know when i first saw the
trailer the first time i didn't know
this movie was coming out i didn't know
what it was about i just saw like the
girls playing tennis and this and that
and then once i once he was like and
what are your girls names and he was
like serena and venus i was like
i literally had chills i was like king
richard it's just like a historical yeah
no it looks amazing and i guess uh the
williams sisters think so too will smith
waited on pins and needles to hear venus
and serena williams's reaction to his
on-screen performance as their father in
king richard out november 19th the oscar
nominee plays richard williams the dad
and childhood tennis coach of the famous
athlete sisters while appearing on the
tonight show on tuesday he recall being
nervous to find out what venus and
sarita thought of the final movie he
said venus and serena were really
excited about the possibility and they
said that they would potentially be
executive producers and they would walk
us through the whole process but they
were going to withhold whether or not
they put their names on the film until
they saw it oh smart so then i get the
call that venus and serena are walking
into the theater to see the film that's
really smart yeah it's the worst two
hours ever the worst two hours because
you spend so much time creating these
things and there's literally only one
audience when you do it you hope that
they like it fortunately the stars
enjoyed the movie he said they cried all
the way through and that they loved it
that's so cute people are saying like
this is going to be will smith's like
oscar moment yeah no it looks incredible
i'm
glad to hear it has the stamp of
approval oh my god i know we should keep
that yeah and that's what i was just
thinking we're all obviously spending
the holidays together and every [ __ ]
holidays we literally spend every night
fighting over what to watch we've
decided to preemptively start a list of
approved films yeah like google start a
google doc of things that like we would
all we all really want to see and then
we're not going to see it until then
none of us will watch it until then what
was the one we already had on it cruella
oh yeah
yeah but that one was just like so good
i need to see it again yeah so add it to
the list add it to the list we actually
like i will physically start a list
nobody has
yeah for like family friendly like boys
girls young old like we just need things
we can all agree on yes that are good we
love a musical too even though we've
really seen them all um
okay it's just we spend so much time
fighting over what to watch no and so
like if we can just preemptively make
our holiday even better why wouldn't we
put in the work now put in the work put
in the hours we take what's hours yeah
it's a viral tick tock song i've heard
it and it sounds like a song from
descendants it's sung by dwayne the rock
johnson and people are
literally demanding he's continue his
rap career because that song went so
viral and did he sing it i don't know
what it's from what it is but it's
recently made a resurgence and people
now are demanding he that's so funny he
rejoined the music industry because he
is the music industry speaking of the
music industry it is such a big week for
music like
i know and jessica simpson just 11 11 11
11. tomorrow
yeah
what are we what's happening um i don't
know maybe a single maybe an album maybe
a christmas song like i don't know but
she's a single would be good she just
threw her hat in the 11-11 ring and you
know what i love that she's like she's
so like
confident in her like she doesn't care
like because i feel like back in the day
she was constantly being compared to
like christina and brittany and it's
like spread out she this is like the
busiest time of year for music right now
and she's just
bye yeah no i'm so excited obviously red
taylor's version comes out tomorrow but
tomorrow she's on thursday friday and
saturday she's snl late night with seth
meyers jimmy fallon
i think maybe she's on one more show
she's just like giving us the most end
the all too well short film which is so
crazy
she's just a musical guest on saturday
right yeah i think who's the host
someone i'd never heard of okay
and
i wonder what she's gonna sing
yes so i saw a theory on tic toc because
you know you get two songs yeah um
and some someone just because of the
timing like someone was like she could
use both of her like song slots to sing
the 10-minute all-too-well version even
though i don't think that's what she's
gonna do because we're getting the
all-too-well
thing i think one of it one of them will
be probably like the most popular single
from the song so like i know you're
trouble we are never getting back
together i know those are my least
favorite ones please no or red or state
of grace state of grace was a single
if she could do state of grace i mean i
would literally die and then the second
performance is probably one of the new
ones okay or oh my god like if she's
saying better like we've never gotten
better man live like we are so desperate
for like let's make our guesses let's
put them in okay let me i think she's
gonna sing red
let me look at the album like get all
the songs in my head i think she's gonna
sing red and a new one and a new one or
better man okay i do think she also is
gonna sing red not to copy off of you
but it's the name of the album it was a
single and it's the best [ __ ] song
yeah but will she do it the same way as
yes okay what i've learned from the
fearless re-recording is that
nothing will change and that's because
these songs at least for me and i think
for a lot of swifties are like literally
like benchmarks in our life like
everything will change
everything that's the worst song um
that like when we want to go back and
reference like moments in our life and
we want to use the taylor's version like
she's given us a carbon copy i
understand no no i know i know but it's
like okay you're gonna go on snl and
perform just the same song that you
would have done in 2013. even though
like for a lot of the songs especially
the ones from 1989 she did unbelievable
remixes of her own songs on tour that i
thought were better than the original
right we've had this conversation so
many times but we need to learn we need
to get it through our heads like no i
think she might do it for 1989 because i
don't think there's any songs that i
would have wanted her to change on red
okay
i just feel like there could always be
harmony just but like one no actually on
1989 she did the most unbelievable cover
of a song from red
and the saddest fear
comes creeping in
that she never loved me
or her wait i know you're trouble yeah
that's red right yeah yeah oh so i guess
she's not doing it that remix is so good
i will not i don't want to hear i knew
you were trouble we're never getting
back together or 20 22.
i agree actually 100
okay what were we saying big musical
weekend yeah and then next week is adele
yeah
and the cmas are tonight
i'm so excited i can't watch i have
somewhere to be i'm so upset
and
what's on
winter house is on tonight yeah i
probably won't watch it either i have
like a busy night i'll be watching the
cmes i'm so excited um okay let's dive
into um vanderpump rules recap brought
to you by honey
when you shop a lot which you know your
girls do honey is the best most
effective thing that you need right now
because it will automatically fill in
the promo code box for you at checkout
but it won't fill it up with just one
code it'll dump a ton of codes in there
every code it can find test them in
seconds and then it'll get you the best
possible discount honey knows where to
look for promo code so you don't have to
it is so fabulous literally you install
it it's a free browser extension the
second you're shopping they will just
when you go to your cart they'll pop up
be like hey [ __ ] you want to save money
and they will just save you money it's
one click it takes a couple seconds is
the easiest thing you could do it's free
and it saves you money and there's
literally not a single reason on the
planet not to have it
get all the promo codes you want at
honey
and you can get it at joinhoney.com
toast that's joinhoney.comtoast
use that link to get the extension for
free it'll download for your browser and
you literally don't have to do anything
else and your life will be forever
changed you're
welcome
let's talk about vanderpump
it's just getting harder and harder to
do that i know let's start with some
some things we liked some positives i
thought the scene at lisa vanderpumps
with lisa ken randall and lala was so
premium and lovely and really i am in a
place right now where i finally savannah
pump just very like not offensive me too
and
dare i say
miss her no not miss her but like
because she's never acted like this
she's always been like inserting her ass
in the middle of like people young
children's drama i just like i'm at
peace with her tabula rasa tabula rasa
at peace that's such a good way and so
whatever she wants to do next like if
she weren't even like to come back to
beverly hills say like
i would be at peace with that i kind of
agree and that's just crazy like that's
time heals all wounds i think she's been
i also think she's been severely humbled
like by
not showing up becoming like a joke on
social media having that failed dinner
party show she's been humbled 100 and
she's
a renewed tabula rasa woman and it's
actually very refreshing and she's also
not inserting herself she hears everyone
out but she doesn't like get involved
which i've always thought was bizarre
like you're an older woman these are
your staff they're 30 years younger than
you like let them hash it out yeah and i
just like that she's there for la la and
even though they had like the culinary
party which i i need to talk about like
in depth um you know lala was actually
wound up on top because she's at a
better swankier event yeah
um let's talk about the okay culinary
first i want to say so
um
the point of the party which was to try
all different foods and so charlie could
you know continue to expand her palette
um
i i that's a cool idea but i would like
doing it at potluck style is like if you
want to try like the best enchilada like
go get an enchilada you know there's
literally so much mexican food in l.a
like
that those plates like that didn't look
appetizing especially as someone else
i eat anything mussels home-cooked right
so it's like all these different foods
that like don't go together it actually
looks like kind of gross and this is a
girl who's easily like grossed out by
food yeah so i was just i felt like it
was counter-productive no i really
related to charlie because i am charlie
like i eat the same four things and i
don't know if i say i have food trauma
because i just like like what i like but
i eat like chicken fingers casey like
i'm charlie like we have the same
palette um and i just want to say from
one you know picky eater to another like
it's not a personality trait and it's
not a story line and we've gotta evolve
like
watching you try different foods like i
have a lot of sympathy for your food
trauma but i'm completely uninterested
to be completely frank no i i understand
it's not gonna cut it i just feel like
if you were to decide to like try new
things like you should go to a different
like gourmet restaurant every night and
really enjoy and not just have this like
potluck dinner that is gross like period
and i don't think that like if you're
gonna try different cuisines and that's
like a journey you want to go on i don't
think we need to watch it
like i really don't okay you know what
else we don't need to watch and this is
the second time that they've done this
and it's the [ __ ] bottom of the
barrel in terms of reality tv let me
guess like their light show
no them playing games
me watching you play a game that's not
two truths and a lie that's not about
it's like a board game yourself
watching you play a board game that's
that doesn't count it doesn't qualify as
television except thank you for
reminding me i have to say like first of
all playing a game with a bunch of drunk
people i have absolutely so much
sympathy for james it is so annoying and
like i am james like when people are not
paying attention to the rules it's so
annoying like why are we sitting around
playing a game if we're all gonna talk
and like not actually play by the rules
like it's so frustrating i was a hundred
percent team james yeah i don't
associate with games i don't like i
don't play them myself let alone
watching other people play them
jackie hates games it's psychotic it's
satanic games are fun
the reason why i hate games if i have to
like boil it down it's like i'm an all
or nothing person so i'm either going to
get extremely into this game and get
very competitive and i have to win or i
can't
i can't be president or i just have to
detach so like i don't want to get like
so competitive like it's embarrassing
and there's already like
i don't want like i just want to chill
out 100
so
i really hate games there are some games
that i have okay like in our fam like we
love games yeah we love games so there
are some things you'll never catch me
doing a puzzle there are games that i
will play you would [ __ ] love puzzles
if you just were stopped stop being so
stubborn like you and your pregnancy
like it's a great activity it gets your
mind running but you don't have to like
do anything you just sit down you can
leave it on the table for days like it's
really you would [ __ ] love puzzles
maybe i'll try it maybe i'll grab the
puzzle that i bought for you that you
still never took home that's why i did
it that's why i did it for you okay
that's not a bad idea but no i will
tolerate monopoly and by the way you
would be unbelievable at puzzles you've
always had like this crazy eye like oh i
dropped my earring back jackie it's over
there like you have this eye for
things like i'm telling you jackie you
could enter like puzzle competitions you
would be so good okay i'm gonna try it
but it's like if i'm not good it's going
to ruin my life no like if it's good
like we could spend our whole bundt of
vacation doing puzzles together that'd
be so much fun okay you know what i'm
open to trying new things and there's
nothing competitive about puzzles yeah
and if i can do it like alone and figure
out if i'm good or not on my own yeah
practice at
okay i will i'll try that but i love
monopoly i like scattergories because
it's a game of skill yeah i do not like
games of luck by the way monopoly is a
game of luck like it's almost is the
game of luck i agree but i i found
we make it fun yeah
literally the best day of my life was
like literally i think i smoked pot and
played monopoly with jackie she was
being
so funny like you
i wish we had recorded that
hour you were being so funny you were
losing you had no money you were
stealing from the bank like
you were being so funny it was just the
best night of my life yeah no see that's
why you should play games it's so fun
and like you're so funny like if you
just played games like do you know how
much better it would make the game okay
i'll try and keep an open mind but i
really don't know so annoying you know
on vacation she'll like literally go to
the other room like she will not play a
game i just really don't like games
you're triggered by the word game like i
don't like games of luck really what
games do you like so i do like
categories yeah um and
i like
sometimes when we play cards against
humanity yeah that's fun um but it gets
old really fast 100 because you go
through the cards and you've seen them
already yeah and
what else do i like
to get i did get a new game for our trip
okay and i think you're gonna like it
okay i don't like code names it's just
like too much of a undertaking code
names i agree like you have to really be
in the headspace for it it's so like
physically laborious you have to like
hover over the table i agree and like
use so much of your brain i have to be
like a hundred percent
like ready and i'm usually not yeah okay
so anyways back to banner prompt rules i
don't want to watch them play games
especially when it's like who can name
all these rappers not like name never
have it never have i ever is fine
because we're getting to know each other
about people whatever um
so that and that's the second time this
season that they've done it they play
the game they play jenga in palm springs
and it's unacceptable it's not it's not
interesting it's not entertainment
you're right let's talk about racquel's
nose because i was loving the batch
crossover me too and like i'm pretty
sure that if she wanted to get her nose
done like he would do it for free
because it's on the show and like right
i don't know i wonder if she if she
winds up going with him yeah i have to
look at her instagram and take a look at
her nose i don't think her nose looks
bad at all but if something's on your
face in the middle of your face and it
bothers you like you don't care if other
people don't notice it because you
notice it yeah i just think racquel
looks so amazing like me too and
it's not even like i don't think she'll
come out like james is saying looking
james is like moronic he is so moronic
um it's just
it's a lot like going for surgery is a
lot like it's just really like you're so
stunning but again it's like what makes
her happy right um and that's just
unfortunate that that's where she's at
yeah but i think she looks awesome me
too and i would love to see paul
nassif's work yeah like if i ever need a
nose job like i am going to pawn ass
like he's the best of the best he's the
nice guy it's also hard to see on tv how
it's um
you know what we need to decide when
they took those pictures in paul navs
nassif's office i'm like oh now i see it
yeah because at first i'm like what i
really didn't before but maybe it's more
noticeable in person
yeah it's nice to know the bump didn't
do anything like lisa trying to make a
mountain out of a molehill like with the
bumping of the nose like but like really
it's not it's not that unheard of like
no it's not but the way that raquel
brought it up yeah it was like wait she
made it the biggest deal and then it's
like oh but you're saying it's not a big
deal that might just make it a big deal
they were acting really strange about it
that's true but i don't i at the end of
the day i i don't think something
nefarious happened either and because
the family was there like
oh my god speaking of nefarious people
brock knowing that sheena's old
boyfriend used to hang a tv in seven
seconds like ever since you implanted in
my brain that he used to watch phantom
from roles it was that and then it was
the adopting the penguin and now it's
the seven minutes a hundred percent yeah
he is the number one fan of vanderpump
rules he knows more about it studied the
playbooks rehearsed his script yeah and
now like just watching this like
basketball game of the toms brock and
james and it's like this is the new like
crew it's pathetic it's just these
people used to be friends right it used
to be a group of friends no now it's a
group of co-workers and that's the worst
type of reality show yeah
yeah it just sucks i can't even get into
how much sandoval bothers me and
honestly tom schwartz is really starting
to bother me too like [ __ ] stick up
for your wife enough can i come to the
restaurant yeah i mean
like shut up she's your wife and she's
actually way smarter than you she just
let her in the restaurant it looks like
next week someone um does testify that
katie is smarter than the toms obviously
yeah she's just like first of all uh
normal like they're both living on
another planet she lives on earth which
is always good she has tons of
restaurant experience from sir she grew
up working in a restaurant and she's
just like level-headed like just
the more they push her out the more this
restaurant is gonna be a big fat flop
yeah
yep yep i wonder if it even winds up
happening i don't know because now what
is this like a year ago like how no it's
like june june
okay like six months ago is there a
restaurant
i don't know we'll see
um so yeah that was vanderpump rules and
that was our show
tomorrow we are here in studio friday's
episode is going to be podcast only
because i will be in los angeles
and that's all we got for you guys thank
you so much right yeah no that's our
show no one else's don't get it twisted
and we'll see you tomorrow thank you so
much for listening to the morning shows
the millennial morning show where we
deliver the fast five stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
on youtube so if you're listening
watching this on youtube please feel
free to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcasts can be found
so that's spotify itunes stitcher public
radio i have radio cast box all the
places so if you listen to podcasts find
us morning shows and leave a five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are we hope you guys have an
amazing day thank you so much for
listening and if you made it to the end
of this episode congratulations why
don't you drop an emoji on our most
recent instagram of the scale in honor
of queen elizabeth mean troll of
weighing all of her christmas guests at
sandringham thank you guys bye